HOI LAM: Android
Wear is great for
quick, glanceable
information that
lets you stay in the present
whilst being connected,
so naturally one of
the most requested
functions is to display
locations on the map.
I'm Hoi Lam, and with the latest
Google Play services update,
Google Maps API has
arrived on Android Wear.
This means best in class
mapping functionality is
only a few lines of code away.
In this Tech Byte, I'll run
you through some common use
cases for the Maps
API on Android Wear,
giving you a head start
on how to implement them.
Before we begin, some good news.
The Google Maps
API on Android Wear
is based on the same APIs on
Android phones and tablets.
As a result, if you have used
the Google Maps API on Android
before, you'll
feel right at home.
One of the most common use cases
is simply displaying a map.
Your app might need to show
a marker to denote a landmark
or display a running route.
In this case, you can use to
Map Fragment, or Map View,
and apply for a
Google Maps API key,
adding markers and polylines
when they're needed.
All of this functionality
is available to you
using the same Maps
API you're already
familiar with on Android,
with just one caveat though.
Android Wear
reserves the gesture
of swiping from left
to right for dismissing
the current application.
If you do not need
your map to pan around,
this will continue to work.
However, if you need your
map to move around and pan,
we need to override this
particular dismiss gesture
to reduce confusion and actually
let our user exit our apps.
To do this, you need to
implement the Dismiss Overly
View, this red
circle with a cross,
and attach it to the
long click event.
The view will handle
the dismiss action.
Another common use case is to
select a location on the map
so that your friend, or your
taxi, can meet you there.
To implement this,
you can place a marker
in the middle of the screen
and let your user pan around
the map.
This indicates the selected
location within a map fragment
element.
Then use the Google Map
onCameraChange listener
to detect if the user has
panned around the map.
You can access the
new location through
the
cameraPosition.target.latitude
and longitude.
You can then send this
information to the recipient,
be it a friend or a taxi driver.
For more technical information
about how to implement the use
case we described
in this Tech Byte,
please head over to
our Maps API blog post.
In addition, more in-depth
reference information
is available on the
Google Developer
portal via this second link.
I'm Hoi Lam.
Android Wear is
designed for a user
to stay connected
whilst on the move.
With the Google Maps
API on Android Wear,
developers have a powerful
tool backed by Google Maps.
So let's keep our users
moving in the real world.